on this one bye-bye [ __ ] this is a
great team onii-chan
what's that how [ __ ] dare say that to
me [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I don't need you
you're just a side [ __ ] two marks yet I
hate you disgust me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you sorry
the owner spell main and then you forgot
my [ __ ] age
[ __ ] you I'm gonna play video games
you're not my [ __ ] mother put me
where I belong
put me in the virtual reality this is my
new reality oh yes this game was made by
Charlie what is this minecraft what is
this [ __ ] Minecraft what are you
doing here oh Jesus Christ
me what the [ __ ] are you doing there
right I'm sorry but games get hard
sometimes okay so oh I got a ball what
is all it's so cute okay just look it's
durable oh can I kiss it oh I can [ __ ]
you Freddy you [ __ ] you oh yeah Oh got a
baseball bat over here do you think I
can grab it guys tell you you'll tell me
if I touch something right the [ __ ] guys
I'm almost at I'm all what the [ __ ] that
is dick
where am I where the [ __ ] happened I'm
almost there I'm almost there I got it
now your honor guys oh I hate the baby
oh that sounded weird what this is not
even the game I guess I should start
playing okay so what it died
alright so I think I need to throw it in
bouncing babies please [ __ ] this is
impossible
oh [ __ ] that was close all right this is
pretty pie for the winning hoop [ __ ]
first try
all right here we go bouncing babies I
love bouncing babies just as much as
bouncing babies babies go there what's
up oh god there's been a fire all right
I'm ready
so with a baby oh god oh god oh my god
you good yeah another one another one
okay oh yes oh God oh [ __ ]
what are you baby gamma what a baby guy
weird oh my gosh fancy [ __ ] hipster
baby what the [ __ ] is is go [ __ ] pigs
stop throwing the babies get the point
I don't you I love you hi trick shot
baby
Oh too many baby I'm got it okay sorry
throwing the fire in the fire
whoops how do i do guys how do i do 12
onii-chan
got 12 babies how many do you get didn't
think so okay let's do another one but
let's do it spice it up a bit
this is too much easy come on babies
come on babies come to pop up here it's
babies oh oh you killed
okay this time what the far you're
throwing penis is it I'm trying to do my
job here we wanted it to fill in your
cash in real babe okay that's good
they're so bouncy
Oh oh my god there we go okay I got it I
got it update you put a baby give me the
baby back hand sad [ __ ]
oops sorry I'm bigger now
oh my god I'm huge dude what the [ __ ]
this is blowing my mind just fish on
this one
bye bye [ __ ]
all right pet panic this is really cool
man
okay look at the vent to start the up
god pumps go there cats go there bring
it on
oh god it's a kid it's a kid all of your
nickel Chan go throwing another it's a
cat
go nail Oh God it's a chicken what the
[ __ ] doing it with a chicken oh God it's
a corgi you're gonna chicken on chicks
go there okay
Corki no [ __ ] no [ __ ] huh okay you go
there you go there ah chicken go there
Cordy there cat there corrugate Kornegay
nail Nick oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't stop oh
come in please no oh you gotta go on
without me cat I can't do it anymore
Cat Cat don't leave me just Nick you
please paste No
Sorry Sorry
and here you know what hands do
now bones things it's part of the game
this is real life you're not supposed to
throw against AI again sorry I have to
throw you to coach I'll do anything
wake up wake up wake up
it's not real life
oh my god
what have I done
thank you so much for watching
leaving like if you enjoyed subscribers
would come abroad today thanks Charles
for letting me play your game and as
always brofist [ __ ] yes I'm flying
through the sky
on that garrisoned dragon
take me to Nandi Allah
sponsoring uh